>> AND JOINING US NOW IS BRETT
EA
EAGLESON, THE PRESIDENT AND
FOUNDER OF 9/11 JUSTICE.
BRETT LOST HIS FATHER ON
SEPTEMBER 11th WHEN HE WAS 15
YEARS OLD.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US.
YOU ARE HELPING TO LEAD WHAT YOU
CALL A FAMILY RALLY AT
BEDMINSTER TODAY.
AND YOU WILL BE SPEAKING.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE THERE?
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
WE EXPECT OVER A THOUSAND FAMILY
MEMBERS TO BE HERE TODAY.
OUR MESSAGE IS VERY CLEAR.
OUR MESSAGE IS TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THAT WE NOW KNOW,
BECAUSE OF FBI DOCUMENTS THAT
HAVE RECENTLY BEEN DECLASSIFIED
BY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WE
NOW KNOW THAT AT LEAST A DOZEN
SAUDI KINGDOM OFFICIALS WERE NOT
JUST IN CONTACT, BUT WERE
ACTIVELY FACILITATING AND
SUPPORTING THE AL QAEDA NETWORK
HERE IN AMERICA 21 YEARS AGO.
THEY WERE SIGNING LEASES.
THEY WERE SIGNING THE HIJACKERS
UP FOR ENGLISH.
THEY WERE INGRATING THEM INTO
THE COMMUNITY.
THEY WERE GETTING THEM SIGNED UP
FOR FLIGHT LESSONS.
IT GOES SO MUCH MORE THAN
SPECULATION AND POTENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT.
WE HAVE AN FBI DOCUMENT THAT
SAYS THE KINGDOM OF SAUDI ARABIA
WAS INVOLVED IN 9/11.
ONE OF THOSE 12 OFFICIALS WAS
ACTUALLY WORKING FOR THE SAUDI
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY.
I CAN'T STRESS THAT ENOUGH.
WORKING FOR THE SAUDI
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY.
AND I'M STANDING HERE IN THE
PARKING LOT OF THE HOTEL, WHERE
ALL THE GOLFERS ARE AT, AND NOT
A SINGLE ONE OF THEM HAVE ANY
IDEA OF WHAT THESE DOCUMENTS
SAY.
AND WE'RE HERE.
OUR NUMBER ONE GOAL IS PUBLIC
EDUCATION, PUBLIC AWARENESS, AND
FOR A FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, WHO IN 2016
HIMSELF SAID THE SAUDIS DID IT.
WHO IN 2019 CHOSE TO INVOKE THE
STATE SECRETS PRINCIPLE AGAINST
THESE DOCUMENTS, IT IS
ABSOLUTELY SHAMEFUL, IT IS
ABSOLUTELY ZDISGUSTING THAT WE
HAVE TO BE HERE TODAY.
COMING OUT IN FULL FORCE,
SHAMING A FORMER PRESIDENT, AND
SHAMING PEOPLE AT LARGE WHO ARE
DOING BUSINESS WITH THIS
SAUDI-FUNDED GOLF LEAGUE.
>> WHAT DOES IT FEEL LIKE FOR
YOU TO BE THERE TODAY?
>> I SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE HERE.
IT'S BEEN 21 YEARS.
THE SAUDIS ARE CURRENTLY
STANDING TRIAL IN FEDERAL COURT
IN MANHATTAN, LESS THAN 50 MILES
FROM WHERE I'M STANDING.
THEY'RE ON TRIAL FOR MURDER.
WE HAVE AN FBI HAS RELEASED
THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF DOCUMENTS.
DOCUMENTS THAT ARE DATED BACK TO
2013, '14, DECADES AFTER THE
CONCLUSION OF 9/11 COMMISSION
REPORT.
HOW IS IT THAT WE HAVE TO BE
HERE AMONGST FAMILY MEMBERS,
STANDING IN SOLIDARITY, AND HAVE
TO SHAME A PRESIDENT?
HOW IS IT THAT WE HAVE TO EVEN
BE HERE IN THE BACKYARDS OF
WHERE 750 PEOPLE WERE BLOWN
AWAY.
THEY WERE BURNED ALIVE.
YOU KNOW, THE SAUDI GOVERNMENT
IS STANDING TRIAL IN NEW YORK.
WE HAVE AN FBI THAT SAYS
CONCLUSIVE THAT THE SAUDIS DID
IT.
AND WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO'S
PROFITING FROM THEM AND
DEFENDING HIS DECISIONS FOR
MAKING MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
AND ONE QUESTION I WISH THE
MEDIA WOULD ASK IS HOW MUCH IS
THE PRESIDENT, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, HOW MUCH IS DONALD
TRUMP PERSONALLY BENEFITTING
FROM THIS RELATIONSHIP?
HOW MUCH MONEY IS HE RECEIVING
TODAY FOR HOSTING THIS
TOURNAMENT?
>> YOU ALSO MAKE THE POINT, AS
YOU ASK THAT QUESTION, HOW MUCH
IS HE PERSONALLY MAKING FROM
THIS, YOU POINT OUT THAT IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION, IT'S SPLIT PRETTY
EVENLY AMONGST PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP.
YOU HAVE PLENTY OF PEOPLE WHO AT
LEAST WERE TRUMP SUPPORTERS, AS
PART OF YOUR GROUP.
WHAT DO THEY THINK NOW?
>> THAT'S A GREAT POINT?
YOU KNOW, 9/11 DID NOT
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN WHETHER
YOU WERE A REPUBLICAN OR A
DEMOCRAT.
IT KILLED US PRETTY EVENLY.
SO SOME OF OUR BIGGEST
SUPPORTERS, SOME OF OUR MOST
OUTSPOKEN ADVOCATES WERE SOME OF
THE BIGGEST TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
SO I HAVE NO QUIDEA WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS DOING.
HE'S HEMORRHAGING REPUBLICAN
SUPPORT OVER THIS ISSUE.
IF YOU ASK MOST REPUBLICANS,
THEY DO NOT LIKE THE SAUDIS.
IF YOU ASK MOST REPUBLICANS
WHERE THEY STAND ON THIS ISSUE,
THEY WOULD 100%, WHOLEHEARTEDLY
BACK OUR ISSUE.
THE 9/11 COMMUNITY DESERVES
JUSTICE.
THAT'S ALL WE WANT.
IS HE WANT JUSTICE AND PUBLIC
AWARENESS, PUBLIC
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF WHAT THE
KINGDOM HAS DONE.
AND EVERYTHING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS DOING FLIES IN THE
FACE OF WHAT HE STANDS FOR.
WE HAVE A FORMER PRESIDENT WHO
CAMPAIGNED ON THE AMERICA FIRST
PRINCIPLE.
ALL HE STANDS FOR IS AMERICA
FIRST.
HE WEARS A HAT THAT SAYS, MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN, BUT HE'S
LITERALLY TAKING MONEY FROM THE
KINGDOM OF SAUDI ARABIA, WHO IS
CURRENTLY STANDING IN TRIAL FOR
MURDER, AGAINST OUR LOVED ONES.
>> FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE, IS HE
LOSING SUPPORT AMONG PEOPLE WHO
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF HIM?
>> HE IS ABSOLUTELY HEMORRHAGING
SUPPORT.
AT LEAST A HUNDRED FAMILY
MEMBERS HAVE REACHED OUT TO ME,
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT VOTE ALONG
REPUBLICAN VOTING LINES, WHO
SAY, I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
HE'S DOING.
I CAN'T STAND HIM.
HE IS JUST LOSING SO MUCH
SUPPORT.
I MEAN, NOT ONLY FROM THE
INDEPENDENT CLASS, BUT HE'S
LOSING REPUBLICAN SUPPORT OVER
THIS ISSUE.
SO, WE CAN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
DONALD TRUMP IS DOING, BUT FROM
WHAT I'M HEARING, FROM WHAT I'M
SEEING, HE IS LITERALLY MEM
RA
HEMORRHAGING SUPPORT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF TYPICAL GROUPS
THAT YOU WOULD EXPECT TO VOTE
ALONG THE CONSERVATIVE LINES,
THEY SAY THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS BASICALLY DEAD TO
THEM.
THAT HE IS ALIGNING HIMSELF WITH
AN EVIL KINGDOM, AN EVIL REGIME.
HE IS PUTTING MONEY OVER
AMERICA.
AND HE JUST, IS JUST SHOWING THE
WORST FORM OF GREED AND THE
WORST FORM OF EVIL THAT WE COULD
EVER IMAGINE.
>> YOU'RE MAKING A STATEMENT
NEAR HIS GOLF CLUB.
IF YOU HAD ANY OPPORTUNITY, AND
I DON'T EXPECT YOU WILL, TO
SPEAK TO HIM PERSONALLY, WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY TO HIM?
>> I WOULD ASK HIM WHAT HE'S
DOING, WHEN DID HE SIGN THIS LIV
CONTRACT?
HOW MUCH IS HE PERSONALLY
BENEFITING?
DID YOU SIGN THIS LIV CONTRACT
BEFORE AND AFTER YOU DECIDED TO
INVOKE THE STATE SECRETS
DOCUMENT.
I MET WITH THE FORMER PRESIDENT
ON 9/11 WITH MY MOM, TWO FORMER
FBI AGENTS AND A DOZEN OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS.
WE PLEADED WITH HIM, PLEASE
DECLASSIFY THE DOCUMENTS.
PLEASE DO IT.
HE LOOKED US IN THE EYE, SHOOK
OUR HANDS, SAID HE WAS GOING TO
DECLASSIFY THESE DOCUMENTS.
LESS THAN 24 HOURS LATER, HIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL INVOKED WHAT'S
KNOWN AS THE STATE SECRETS
PRINCIPLE.
IT BASICALLY BLOCKED ALL THIS
INFORMATION FROM COMING TO
LIGHT.
INFORMATION THAT WE NOW HAVE,
THANKS TO THE BIDEN PRESIDENTIAL
EXECUTIVE ORDER, WHICH UNWOUND
THE STATE SECRETS PRINCIPLE
DESIGNATION.
HE KEPT THOSE DOCUMENTS SECRET
FOR A REASON.
HE WAS PROTECTING THE SAUDI ROLE
IN 9/11.
AND TO BE FAIR, OTHER PRESIDENTS
HAVE DONE IT AS WELL, BUSH,
OBAMA.
THEY HAVE ALL DONE IT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN UNWOUND HIS
DECISION TO SEAL THESE
DOCUMENTS.
SO I WOULD ASK HIM, WHAT WERE
YOU THINKING?
AT WHAT POINT DID YOU ENGAGE IN
THIS CONTRACT WITH LIV?
HOW MUCH MONEY ARE YOU GETTING?
HOW MUCH DOES IT TAKE TO BUY YOU
OFF?
WHAT DOLLAR AMOUNT IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN AMERICAN LIVES,
AMERICAN VALUES?